Speaker 1: Donald Trump's tax returns are going
public on Friday. It's finally happening. We
already know much of what is in those tax returns,
thanks to the report issued by the January
six committee. But we're getting them. The tax
returns are going to be released Friday and it's
going to be wild. NBC News reporting Trump tax
returns to be released to the public on Friday.
The Ways and Means Committee voted last week to
make six years of Trump's tax returns public.
This was a party line vote. Initially, the
plan was to release the documents as early
as last Wednesday. The disclosure was delayed
due to having to redact personal information
like Social Security numbers. The assortment
of six years of Trump's personal tax returns
and some of his business returns are expected to
be placed into the Congressional Record Friday.
The clock is ticking for the committee, which
will turn over control to Republicans when the
new Congress is sworn in next week. Another report
from Reuters. Former Republican President Donald
Trump's redacted tax returns will be made public
on Friday. The documents to be released Friday are
expected to include a Trump's tax returns between
2015 and 2021, the years he ran for and served as
president. A spokesperson for Trump declined
to comment. Trump was the first presidential
candidate in decades not to release his tax
returns during either of his campaigns for
president. So beyond the Trump aspects of this,
what are we going to learn from the Trump aspects?
Okay, we've gone over it so many times. He's not
as rich as he claims to be. He has sketchy debts
that raise questions about being compromised in
national security. He uses this. Some would call
it fraudulent technique of inflating the value
of assets when he wants to use the asset as
collateral for a loan, but diminishing the value
of an asset when it's for the purposes of figuring
out how much tax he's going to owe on that asset.
There's the Trump aspect to it. We already learned
most of those things are true from the summary
the House released, and we will get, I believe,
beyond a shadow of a doubt, confirmation
from the tax returns themselves. Beyond that,
there are banks that will maybe end up under
pressure after these tax returns are released
to know from people wanting to know from those
banks, why did you keep loaning this guy money
when his finances were clearly bad? How did
you accept this valuation for a building
that was serving as collateral when it's so
clearly was not the value of the building?
So I believe there's going to be attention on
banks and whether the banks were sort of like
look the other way or whether the banks were
complicit in what some would call a fraud.
We are also going to see potentially the
argument made that, you know, something is
partizan and biased here because there has never
been this much attention about any president's
tax returns. The right is going to say, you
know, this is all a politically trumped up
witch hunt. Way to go after Donald Trump, because
you've never seen so many people waiting for the
tax returns of another president. Well, no other
president. Refused to release their tax returns
and then worked for six years to prevent their
release. That's why there is a spotlight on this
and they will claim. The problem is that
people are eager to see the tax returns. Now,
the reason we're even in this situation is
because Trump did something nobody else has done,
which is to say, I'm just not going to release
them now. He did say, I will release them once.
They're no longer being audited, but they weren't
being audited. And you all know the lies. But the
point here is what's unique isn't that the tax
returns are coming out. It's that they had to
come out via this means because Trump refused to
otherwise provide them. So don't fall for that
when we certainly hear from Republicans, you
know, this is political partizanship because
Democrats are excited about the tax returns. Now
it's Trump who did the thing nobody else has done.